I'm Renee T and I'm going to be talking
about advice from my podcast guests
about becoming a data scientist and my
podcast is called becoming a data
scientist you can go to becoming a data
scientist calm and there's links to
everything there so I'm going to
actually breeze through some of the
slides because I want to make sure to
get through a lot so you can always go
back through the slides later I will
post them but to highlight here I just
wanted to let you know that I'm a data
scientist at Helio campus and that's new
I just became a data scientist
officially with the title as of July and
Helio campus does data analysis on
educational data from universities and
also I host the podcast and I also have
a data science learning club that I
don't teach or do anything there but I
post activities and then people in the
club there are over 500 members but not
all of them are actively participating
but 90 of them have actually posted
something so you can always go to the
data science learning club and find
resources that other people are posting
around the different activities so
that's kind of my background I'm also on
Twitter I have about 95 hundred
followers and so it become kind of like
a connection point so sometimes when
people have data science questions
they'll tweet me and I'll retweet it and
then other people will answer it
so feel free to tweet me if you have any
questions so these are the guests of my
podcast and you'll be hearing from them
throughout the presentation so I get
asked this question a lot how do I
become a data scientist and my common
refrain is it depends it always depends
so we're going to talk today about where
to start to become a data scientist who
to listen to and who not to listen to
what to learn how to learn how to
practice and how to know when you're
ready and I will have a lot of resources
but they're going to be at the end and
they're not going to be a part of the
presentation so you can get them in the
slides later but I'm not going to talk
about specific websites or books or much
of that during the presentation
okay so first let's talk about where to
start so a lot of people ask me where
should I start
but what they really mean is where do I
even start there's so much information
it's kind of overwhelming
have you guys been a little bit
overwhelmed by the variety of
information here even just at this
conference it's a lot right how many of
you are brand new to data science and
just kind of getting into the field oh
good a lot of you alright so again the
answer is it depends so there's this
path to becoming a data scientist and in
order to figure out what path you need
to take you first need to figure out
where you currently are and where you
want to go so this is from Stargate if
you guys are familiar with the movie
this is where James Spader is explaining
what the six symbols on the Stargate
mean that that's the the address to
where the Stargate is going to take you
when you walk through it and the
scientists had already figured out that
but that figure that part out but they
wanted to know well what is the seventh
Chevron what is this other symbol we
can't figure it out we can't activate
the Stargate and he said well you need
to have a starting point that's the
starting planet and there's all kinds of
discussion online about the physics of
this six points and seven points it it
doesn't matter the point is that he's
starting on a planet and he needed
another starting point in order to know
where to go so he connects the two he
plays a really good nerd by the way okay
so you're going to be assessing your
starting point and your path planning
out a path and then where you're going
but both the starting point and the
ending point and the path they're all
customed to you so my husband when I
showed him that he said well that looks
like a Fineman path integral and so you
started talking about there are infinite
ways to go from point A to point B I
said well that's kind of the point right
and they started telling me all the
physics behind it and getting into this
and that's just not my thing so that's
that's the last equation you'll see in
this presentation but he was right there
infinite number of ways so to figure out
where you're starting from you need to
kind of assess where you are and we'll
talk about the different categories of
topics to learn in data science but you
need to think about things like how much
math have you taken when you last took
math how comfortable were you with it
have you ever programmed in what
language and how advanced were you last
time you programmed have you ever done
basic data analysis on a professional
level before and in what domain so there
are all these baseline questions that
you need to ask
to figure out where you're starting from
and there's this book called doing data
science by Cathy O'Neil and Rachel shot
and it gives a good overview of just the
different categories of things that you
need to know and it points you at
different resources throughout and it's
based on a course that was taught and
they went through these different
categories of the people that came in to
speak to the classroom what kind of
skills did they have but what was cool
they had this this profile in the book
where they would show each data
scientist only has a subset of these
skills and nobody's an expert at
everything right and so the cool thing
now is that companies are creating teams
where they're putting together data
scientists with different skill sets so
that they can create a team with the
skill set that they need so you have to
think about what kind of data scientist
do you want to be you're not going to be
an expert in everything there's
different titles that kind of go along
with data scientists or that are now
called data scientists that weren't
before so if you really love solving
business problems with data and working
with people and being kind of customer
facing a lot of those roles are called
data analysts that's kind of the area
that I'm in but also known data
scientists when you add on machine
learning and some other techniques if
you really like working with the code
and working in the backend and the big
data systems you might gravitate towards
more of a data engineer a big data
engineer but if you really like doing
the research and more of the academic
side you could do something like a
machine learning researcher and develop
new machine learning algorithms you
could be a statistician looking at
certain domains of data but you can also
call yourself a data scientist so
there's overlap here and here's a lot of
the different titles that now call
themselves data scientists so you can
see there's all kinds of different
domains and fields and I think that this
is what's exciting about being a data
scientist now is that there are really a
lot of different ways to go with it and
you can apply data science techniques to
just about any area so I find that
exciting that you're not boxed in and so
to figure out what kind of data
scientist you want to be you want to
find somebody that can be a role model
somebody that's kind of doing what you
eventually want to do and you can talk
to them or you know watch my podcast I
try to interview a variety of people and
find out what is it they do day to day
and how did they get there you can look
job listings online to figure out what
to do what to learn but be aware that
that's kind of problematic some of the
job listings they the companies don't
really know what they're looking for or
they don't really know what a data
scientist is so they just list
everything and the listing so if there's
a job listing that has like way too many
things just be aware you don't have to
know all those things to get a job like
that they're probably just listing their
whole wish list and hoping that they get
somebody with a subset of that but job
listings can be a good way to figure out
the different types of data scientists
and the expectations as data scientists
you mean like a conferences or online
and I said join the conversation on
Twitter because I found that there's a
really good data science community on
Twitter like I said I have like 9,500
followers it's there are a lot of people
learning data science and a lot of
people that are already data scientists
sharing what they do and also there's a
lot of women in data science on Twitter
which is what I like I have a list
I've been compiling and if you want to
be on the list and you're not on it let
me know but I have over 800 women in
data science on my Twitter list so far
so when you're planning out your path
you want to keep it pretty general but
know the waypoints along the way so if I
wanted to go from where I live in
Harrisonburg Virginia up to Boston I
want to know I would definitely want to
go through DC and see the monuments but
I don't want to plot out exactly the
path I just want to know the specific
points and then my GPS is going to tell
me along the way well okay you're going
to go through DC and so I said great I
can stop and see all the monuments in DC
but then when I'm getting close I found
out about why traffic you know the
monuments aren't that important I'm
trying to get to Boston so just be ready
to kind of reroute and figure out
basically as you go you're going to find
different things that you need to learn
gaps you need to fill in in order to get
where you're going and the things that
you initially thought you might need to
learn might change along the way so
that's okay you don't have to plot every
single point this is Trey Kazi one of my
podcast guests and so when I was talking
to him about all these things to learn
his advice was that part of being a data
scientist is being okay with not
understanding everything you're going to
be doing yourself a disservice if you
set out to learn all of the different
topics that people say that you should
learn you're going to ask 10 people and
get 12 answers
and Stephanie said it's going to be your
job for the rest of your life so if
you're going to get really good at
something make sure it's something you
enjoy because it requires a lot of
persistence and curiosity to be happy
and successful so don't force yourself
into something follow what you enjoy so
in other words with all this variety of
things you can learn under the umbrella
of data science you can just pick what
you like you don't have to learn
everything that you don't like and
you'll still be valuable so this is your
chance to become a candidate for your
dream job and decide what you want to
learn and then make it fun it doesn't
have to be like school and it doesn't
have to be somebody else's program okay
my timer just reset so can somebody give
me a ten-minute heads-up okay so once
you have an idea about this possible
path who do you turn to for guidance so
when to talk about who to listen to and
who not to listen to so when you're
getting on a ride you might have the
sign that says you have to be this tall
to ride right there's like a gatekeeper
there but there's people like that in
tuk too they'll say to be a real data
scientist you have to be a PhD you have
to be a computer scientist you got to be
from a top school we only hire people
from Stanford you have to be
traditionally educated right none of
that's true I mean you'll meet data
scientists with all different kinds of
backgrounds so what they're really
saying is you have to be just like me
and the people that I know because I got
here and they're their pattern matching
to their own experience and and they're
their limiting the kind of people they
can hire so you don't want to listen to
people like that and what they'll say if
they're honest is like Isaac Newton said
I've seen further by standing on the
shoulders of giants so the ones that you
do want to listen to are the people that
will say hey here the resources that
helped me here's how I got to where I am
they're not trying to block you and
they're not making assumptions about you
they're just saying here's how I got
here I'm trying to help you get there so
who not to listen to the gatekeepers
like I said you have to be a certain
thing the naysayers you just aren't cut
out to be a data scientist or in the
past like you failed math what are you
even thinking you sure don't look like a
data scientist
so you guys might remember the Twitter
campaign that was hashtag
I look like an engineer and that came
from this ad in the subway where I think
her name is Isis on Chile and somebody
put on line they said you know she
doesn't look like an engineer they
probably just hires a model to try to
attract men and so she went and said yes
I am she started the hashtag I look like
an engineer I helped build enterprise
software I'm an engineer right so don't
listen to those people and then there's
the scoffers they'll be like oh it's so
easy if you're not getting this year
just not cut out for it right you guys
know about Nick burns the your company
computer guy on SNL he comes into the
office and people are saying I have a
tech problem I don't know what to do
with my computer's froze and he'll say
wait did you try this this this isn't
this and like I don't even know what
those things are and he'll say move and
he just wants to take their place like
forget it you don't understand I'll do
it for you don't listen to those people
if you're trying to learn and then your
own doubts right so sometimes you're the
one telling yourself that if I'm already
struggling I just shouldn't be in this
field like it turns out that a lot of
women will drop out of computer science
if they aren't getting A's in their
introductory class but it turns out that
a lot of men will stay in the program if
they're getting A's B's C's whatever
they figure out how I'll figure it out
as I go along so don't count yourself
out too early so who do you listen to
like I said earlier the honest and
helpful people who have been there they
say oh I got stuck there too here's here
are the my resources your supporters
they're saying oh you're so awesome at
that one thing you know that that thing
you've got it down keep going I can't
wait to do see you do this next project
that you're working on and you want to
listen to experts that know how to teach
beginners so good teachers sometimes
people are experts but they forget what
it was like to be a beginner and they
can't communicate right but you want to
listen to people that say well let's
walk through this I'll show you how it
works
and then your confidence off like I can
do this I just need more resources I
just need another book I just need
someone to explain this one concept to
me
so for guidance find people that are the
type of data scientists that you want to
become good teachers that know how to
communicate with beginners other
beginners are also good resources you
know other people that maybe are just
ahead of
you on the learning path and they could
tell you well that thing caught me up or
that that course really didn't help me
and then mentors and friends who share
your passion are in the domain you want
to work so if you want to find a mentor
find somebody with the same interest as
you so that you can kind of follow along
with them and they understand what
you're trying to get at so I'll tell you
data science is not easy I've struggled
with it a lot it's not even very
well-defined so if nobody knows what
data science is how can you say it's
easy it's also not too hard for you like
a part of it might be hard for you right
now but you're going to get there so you
just have to find the right resources
and stick with it and it's up to you not
to get derailed because this isn't like
school where they're just going to pass
you to the next level and you'll
graduate you're the one determining what
you learn how far you go so we'll talk a
little more about how to learn in part
five first let's say what to learn so
what do I need to learn to be a data
scientist you know the answer it depends
so I don't want to go into details here
but this is just some example they
designed this careers in the different
skill sets but the concept I'm trying to
get across is that you need these four
categories no matter what area of data
science you go into so math and
statistics computer science and machine
learning data visualization and
communication and business domain
knowledge
I put business in quotes because it
doesn't mean business like marketing
it's just like the domain that you're
going into it could be a research
science but you'll see all that all of
them are checkmarks there's none that
are missing but some of the checkmarks
are bigger so for instance if you want
to be a machine learning developer you
better understand computer science and
the statistics behind it so first you
learn the basics and there's kind of a
joke in data science because there's a
lot of Venn diagrams out there about
what data science is but this one has
mathematics computer science and domain
expertise and you can see what's in the
different intersections there and then
the middle that's data science so I have
a list of what I think are the bare
minimums that you need to learn first is
undergraduate level descriptive
statistics obviously you can go a lot
further with statistics if you want to
but at least like a undergraduate level
intro course is a minimum you also want
to know how to visualize data how to
make a good chart that can communicate
things on the computer science side you
have to at least be able to code to
manipulate data and
summarize the the information and one
language like Python and then you want
to at least be able to run some of the
package machine learning techniques so
you might not understand the calculus
and statistics and algorithms behind the
scenes but you know how to apply them
and generally what they mean and how to
test to see if the results were good and
then the domain knowledge you you should
have an area that if you want to go into
a specific area should at least be able
to do like a simple business
intelligence type of report which is you
know a summary of a spreadsheet type of
thing maybe even Excel and then be able
to communicate your understanding of the
information to different people in the
in the domain and understand the
terminology so that's kind of the
minimum baseline when you get in but
then you also need to become a
specialist in some area and you can pick
what that area is so it might be
something like machine learning and AI
so you might learn more about deep
learning autonomous systems computer
vision natural language processing
you might learn how to make really
pretty data visualizations like for
publication be a data journalist you
could focus on the big data engineering
side and work on things like Hadoop
spark you might go into the geographic
data and mapping techniques and work on
a GIS system or it might be that the
domain is your specialty like you come
from a specific research science
background or you want to focus on
educational data or politics or
marketing so maybe the domain becomes
your expertise Claire Cornell has an
online open source data science master's
program that she outlined all the
different things that she learned while
she was going through learning data
science and I asked her should somebody
go through this whole list if they want
to be a data scientist and she said
absolutely not you should cherry-pick
and be very strict about what you
include because you could spend your
whole life on one of these topics that's
under the umbrella of data science so
find a niche within that area and get
good at that one thing experts are
usually experts at one thing this is
Sofia she said it's dangerous ideology
the notion of a super genius so some of
us just imagine that there's these
people out there that are good at
everything they're just data science
geniuses and you know they're not and
that's dangerous because it makes you
feel like you can never get there but
they've got there by learning and
practicing and focusing on a certain
area and you know making sure they get
good at it
the idea of a super geniuses is she's
right that's dangerous notion and then
Justin says get experience a lot of the
data science skills I've developed are
out of interest if I have a problem
that's in front of me I'll figure out
what I need to learn to solve that
problem so he started in music and then
became a neuroscientist and always an a
data scientist as well and he just
figured it out as he went along
I mean he's also a PhD so he had a lot
of academic background but I heard this
again and again from different guests on
the podcast that I just had a project I
wanted to do and so I figured out what I
need to learn next to do the next step
of that project if you're a total
beginner I recommend start by creating a
report so this might just be finding a
dataset online and an area you're
interested in summarizing in and Excel
make some charts make sure you can
explain what's going on there so a basic
data analysis that answers a business
question and like I said business
doesn't have to be like marketing it
could be any domain so I consider this
to be the baseline for anyone that calls
himself a data analyst or a data
scientist you should be able to take a
business question like somebody asks you
something and says this is what I want
to do this is what I want to optimize or
I'm not trying to figure this out and
understand that question enough to turn
it into a data question and say here's
the data that you need to answer that
question here's how we can find that
data and then be able to do the answer
here's how we can analyze that data
right here's the summary and then turn
it back into a business answer so you
don't want to give that person like some
statistical result of how well your
model fit the data you want to be able
to turn it back into here's what it
means so don't just focus on the
technical tools and techniques that you
need to learn the non technical skills
are just as important and this kept
coming up in the interviews so Sherman
he's in marketing analysis and he does
some data science himself and hires data
scientists so he said the number one
thing that I look for is curiosity the
value-added is by saying I found this
and I'm curious how did that happen and
taking the analysis to another level so
the soft skills that came up often in
the interviews where things like
curiosity the ability to communicate
with a variety of people the
to hear the problems a lot of times
people will like assign you a problems I
do this analysis but you need to
understand what is it they're really
trying to get at so you're not just
doing like answering a question you're
trying to understand what is their real
question behind that the desire to
continue to learn you're going to be
learning on the job
creativity for problem-solving tenacity
and average he's the author of guerrilla
analytics and he has a list in that book
of things that he expects data analysts
to have the skill set but he said that a
critical part of the data scientist
mindset is tenacity you've got to be
able to keep going at a problem right
and get overcome it and dr. [ __ ]
argaman he's a professor at IIT he's the
director of the Masters of data science
program there I asked him so what are
the common traits of your most
successful students and he talked about
being able to overcome unexpected
difficulties so if there's some weird
row of data you know you don't just give
up and come into class the next day and
say well I got stuck you know I need
your help but to be able to figure out
what is it about that row of data why am
I getting stuck what is this arrow mean
and then I add a recognition of wider
issues that come into play for instance
bias that could be introduced in a
machine learning algorithm so thinking
of the bigger system and what kind of
impact your analysis is going to have so
I made another data science Venn diagram
you're welcome
and the the combination hero I want to
also say that stuff to Silva helped me
with this on Twitter so I tweeted a
early sketch of what I was thinking and
and she filled in a lot of the gaps here
so the common themes like I just talked
about folk kind of center around
curiosity creative problem solving and
communication so those are the three
circles there but what are the overlaps
so if you take out curiosity you've got
creative problem solving and
communication so a person with these two
skills they can answer the questions
that are asked and communicate that
answer but they're not doing that value
ad that Sherman was talking about
they're not going beyond and trying to
answer the real question that's being
asked and diving in deeper about why
without creative problem-solving you
might be curious and be able to
communicate so you do some great
research you really define the problem
well you can talk to the people asking a
question but you're not offering them
any actionable solutions like well what
can I really do
this result and if you have the creative
problem-solving than the curiosity you
might have a perfect data science
analysis but if you can't communicate
that to the end user then it's just an
unintelligible presentation of otherwise
good results and that's useless they
don't know what you're talking about
so at the intersection is good data
science practice and these three things
were mentioned consistently by the
guests as either traits that they
themselves had or things that they look
for when they're hiring a data scientist
or things that set people apart there
are a lot of people that know the
technical side that don't have this
non-technical side and that's really
what can set you apart in an interview
so don't have this list of technical and
non-technical things to learn so now how
do you go about learning it it depends
so you want to choose resources that
work with your learning style and
customize it it's a lot of people always
ask me you know what's the best thing
you use to learn data science well that
might not necessarily help you so I have
a list of resources at the end but it's
a long list because you might like
videos you might like books more you
might like the interactive coding sites
more so there are a lot of different
resources out there it's a little bit
overwhelming which is why I started a
website called data saw guide that I can
talk about afterwards if you're
interested but the idea is to have
people in data science at different
skill levels rate whether the resource
was helpful for them at that time but
you have to customize it to your
learning style and you have to overcome
your math and programming aversions so I
came out of high school I went to the
Science and Technology School but I went
into college saying I don't want to take
any more math than I have to and I hope
I never have to program again because I
hated it in high school but then it
turned out that the program I was in at
James Madison University it was
integrated Science and Technology and we
had to take kind of baseline courses in
everything and the the programming class
that I had to take there was totally
different and it was focused on like
building an interface and solving a
real-world problem and not just you know
solving a math problem and so that got
me interested again so you don't have to
love math and programming but you have
to not hate them in order to learn them
and there's this really great TED talk
with Sal Khan from Khan Academy and he
talks about let's not teach for mastery
I mean let's teach for mastery not test
scores and so his his idea is that
school has traditionally worked is that
you teach a whole class you're bringing
them all along together and you might
have students that get you know 60 70 80
90 % but you you pass them to the next
level and you say well you got an 80
that's good enough we're moving on class
can't wait for everybody and then you've
got these people in class that are
missing 20% of the foundational
information they need before they move
on then they start feeling lost and then
you start hating it right so that's why
a lot of people hate math and
programming because I got lost at some
point and felt stupid so the point is
that you can try it a different way now
and his point in the talk was that we
now have systems that can customize that
learning per student we don't have to
bring them all along as the same class
but when you're teaching yourself you
can keep going at it until you feel like
you've mastered that you can keep asking
until you understand something so
there's not that pressure and you can
you can do it yourself and use a lot of
different resources right I don't know
if you many of you guys ever played the
old school game called lemmings if you
haven't maybe you're more familiar with
Angry Birds but these are puzzle games
where you have to keep going at
something and figure out something and
repeat the level over and over until you
get it and then you finally solved it
and what do you get next a harder level
so people that like this kind of game I
have the patience and persistence and
problem-solving skills to play them if
you have that enough to play and move
forward in the game you probably the
same skills you need to program that
game so those are the that's the same
kind of concepts you go through when
you're coding so now that you know what
to learn how do you practice it right
you've learned that you know what to
learn you know how to learn it but now
what do you do to put it in real-world
context the most common advice that I
keep hearing is to start a project
related to something that matters to you
and I really recommend this as well so
you want to find a real-world data set
there's lots of free datasets online if
you need help finding one I have a lot
of links that can help or you can
generate your own data one of the data
science learning club members Verena she
put GPS collars on her cats and tracked
them walking around her neighborhood or
you can track you know information from
like a fitbit about yourself find
something that matters to you and then
ask questions that could be answered
about that day
and then each step of your project means
you're going to learn a new topic or a
new skill or technique and then I also
recommend blogging about your
experiences and sharing it I think
that's kind of why my blog and podcast
took off without it being you know super
polished is just because I would share
it as I went along
I wouldn't wait until I had some final
version that was ready to present people
like seeing me struggle because they're
going through the same thing and that's
what's helpful to them so share it and
if you don't want to write on a blog
then record yourself talking about it or
something you have to make sure you're
getting feedback that you're doing it
right
of course there always be people that
will tell you you're doing it wrong no
matter what but at least you can get
some of that feedback and then also
whether you're communicating the results
will so will said my answer is to always
read a lot of books and study every
night when people ask him about learning
data science and then they ask him well
how else no one likes that answer that
it's just consistent repeated practice
and learning and then Sebastian had a
good metaphor he said how I learned best
is really by struggling if you're
lifting weights and you only lift the
small weights you'll never become any
stronger and there's also the converse
of that if you just try to lift a giant
weight you're going to hurt yourself
not want to lift weights anymore right
so it's definitely a process and you
want to move yourself along I'm reading
this book right now called peak secrets
from the new data science it's a new
sign from the new science of expertise
and they have this concept called
deliberate practice which is based on a
lot of real research and their point is
that inherent talent doesn't determine
who becomes an expert and also there's
really no such thing as inherent talent
a lot of people that seem to be good at
things as kids often just started
earlier and have done it more often but
also somebody that practices something
every day and this is the research that
10,000 hour rule came out of which turns
out not to be totally applicable to
everything it was a specific part of the
research but it's the concept of if you
spend something like 10,000 hours on a
topic you're going to get better but
they wanted to make the point it's not
just spending time on the topic it's
this deliberate practice of pushing just
beyond where you are so if you just go
out and play tennis every day
a you can play every single day for your
whole life you might not get better you
have to have a specific technique that
you want to get better at practicing a
specific skill having feedback and
guidance from a teacher that can tell
you well you're holding the racquet a
little bit wrong here and it's specific
goal if you want to get better at
serving you're going to do practice a
little differently than if you want to
get better at you know making sure you
return the ball so this is a good book
if you want to learn about becoming an
expert so then how do you know when
you're ready to take the next career
step or apply for a job it's not going
to be like in the matrix where you have
a plug in the back of your hand you say
whoa I know data science it doesn't feel
like that you know you actually will
made the comment in the podcast he's
Episode one and I think that's a really
good episode that you kind of always
feel dumb when you're in data science
because there's always something else to
learn it's always the next thing right
and Aaron said I think that people
overestimate what you need to know to
get started in this field so you can be
a junior level and you can apply for
jobs and just let people know like
here's what I know I'm just starting out
here are my skills I think I can help
you but also I can learn on the job from
your existing data scientists and I
personally felt ready when I knew I had
those foundational skills I was
comfortable with the terminology so when
I talked to people about data science I
wasn't totally lost I had accomplished a
few difficult things and that made me
realize well if I can get through these
several difficult things in a row then I
can learn anything else on the job like
I've got the foundation I've gotten from
end to end on a few different projects
I'm ready and then there's nothing wrong
with doing a few stretch interviews for
practice so you can apply for a job when
you're not quite ready and you'll get
the feedback of you know what type of
things were they looking for where were
your gaps and it is hard to apply for
jobs and be rejected a lot and data
science is a competitive field but there
are a lot of jobs out there so you might
have to go on several interviews before
you get one but you're going to find one
that's a good match for you but there's
nothing wrong with trying them just for
practice and see how far you go you
might get hired anyway so in summary you
probably learned today
it depends that's always going to be
answer but what that means is that you
have to customize the advice that you
get so hopefully I've given you some
guidance on how to do that and how to
get started on the path to your data
science dream job so here's what we
talked about figure out where you're
starting from and what kind of data
scientists you want to be and map out
that path but not to specifically learn
those required baseline topic
descriptive statistics coding enough to
manipulate and summarize simple machine
learning and a solid analytical
understanding and some domain get good
at a specific niche beyond the basics
deliberately practice those technical
skills and soft skills with real-world
data and don't forget to get feedback
and then you're never going to be done
learning so don't wait too long to try
applying for a data science related job
you're going to have to just go for it
and most importantly have fun while
you're doing it it's hard it won't feel
fun while you're in it but then when you
finish something and you're getting it
working it's really fun as exciting
Debbie Berra Beaches was one of my
podcast guests and she's a physicist and
the chief data scientist at Metis when I
asked her you know what's your bottom
line advice to data science learners or
people like you and how you started out
she didn't say you know take a data
science bootcamp even though she works
at Metis she said what's most important
is to not let anyone take your dreams
away to know that they're there for a
reason and you have them because they're
part of your essence and if you choose
not to listen to that voice that's
telling you one day you're going to pay
for it and be unhappy so pursue your
dreams no matter how hard you think they
are in the moment and find a mentor so I
think that's a good summary of
everything I've been trying to say so
questions
okay so the question was the actionable
solutions part on once you do the
analysis and hand it over how do you get
to that point where you can make
suggestions for what to do so in order
to do that that's why you need the
domain knowledge so you really
understand what's being asked and what
they're trying to get at so you might
not be able to give a business
suggestion because that's not your
expertise but knowing what they're
asking you should be able to give some
guidance within that question so you can
say you know your question was this and
here's the wide range of possibilities
and I'm seeing that this particular
possibility is probably the most likely
to get you where you want to go so you
know I'm not going to say it in
statistical terms but you know you could
see a certain chart maybe and you know
this section shows that this is where
you should focus so it could be
something like that where you're not
you're not telling them what to do as a
business but you're telling them based
on the analysis here it is in your term
so that you can take it and move forward
with it
other questions
if you go into a niche it means like
you're boxing yourself in okay so the
question is about how do you balance out
between learning things that are in a
certain niche and then learning the wide
variety of things since you're supposed
to be a fast learner and picking things
up without boxing yourself in so the
niche I was talking about was for
something that you want to do and become
good at as an expert and you still need
that baseline across everything so once
you have that baseline and you know that
you can pick up anything you're aware
that if you spent enough time and enough
practice you could pick up any other
area but the niche is where you want to
focus so it's not that you're boxing
yourself in from learning anything else
but it's that first you have to get
solid footing and something to be able
to say this is the type of data
scientist I am so I would say once you
have those baselines and you spend a lot
of time and your niche and that's where
you do your projects and you make sure
that everything's kind of centered
around that like if your niche is data
visualization you could do a lot of
different kind of projects but you make
sure that each time you spend extra time
on that data visualization so you're not
stopping yourself from learning
something else but you're getting
especially good at that one thing I hope
that answers it yes uh-huh
okay so finding a mentor right sometimes
it could be somebody on your current
team that you're like kind of apprentice
endure sometimes it could just be
somebody in the field like maybe if
you're a physicist you might look at
what Debbie did and how she got went
from physics to becoming a data
scientist so it might not be a mentor
that you're actually like talking to one
on one necessarily though that's it's
good to have somebody like that it could
just be somebody that you look up to and
you study how they got to where they are
and then sometimes they're accessible
like Debbie will answer tweets on
Twitter so once you kind of figure out
well here's how she got and here's where
I'm stuck maybe I'll ask her that
specific question so it's not that you
need someone that you can call up all
the time and like personally guide you
through but somebody that is going or is
already at where you're going and and
someone thought you can follow and I
think probably the domain is more
important than the specific techniques
if when you're looking for a mentor like
you don't just necessarily find the one
that's has the same
technical niche that you're going for
but it's in the same domain so you can
talk to them about the type of problems
that need to get solved and am i
positioning myself to be valuable in
this industry so it's not maybe not the
traditional description of a mentor but
there's kind of that whole range from
like someone you're actually working
with side-by-side all the way to just
somebody that's a really good role model
but that's willing to share information
so the question was about the balance
between theory and practice so because
of the variety people coming in to do
data science I find that some people
come from more of like an academic
research theory background and they feel
like I have to know all the theory
before I can get into the practice you
don't want to restrict yourself from
getting to applying it like actually
doing the projects is good but then
there's people on the other side that
just say I want to apply this black box
algorithm apply everything and get an
output but I don't really care what it
means inside you don't want to be on
that side either so it is a balance I
would say that you would want to make
sure to understand the theory at least
within the niche of what you're doing of
why that specific area what are the
theories behind what you're learning in
that area so you make sure that the area
that you're saying that you're more
expert in that you do understand those
theories with machine learning
algorithms you're saying used to want to
study how each of them learnt works if
there's a certain one that you find
yourself using repeatedly or that comes
up a lot in the industry that you're in
I would say make sure you fully
understand behind the scenes how that
one works and that will give you a
concept of how machine learning in
general works you know understanding the
math behind it the computer programming
behind it maybe diving into you know a
lot of the packages are open-source so
you can actually look at the code behind
them and how it works and studying one
very thoroughly that will give you
probably enough footing to be able to
translate that and understand something
else or talk to somebody that has worked
something else without having to go
through that entire process for every
single algorithm you might apply so it
is a balance I would say you need at
least enough theory in the area that
you're focusing on but the practical
part is really important companies care
about what can you do for me but they
also care do you understand what you're
doing but they don't want you to be so
hung up in the theory that you're never
get anything done
other questions yes it looks like you're
almost implying that you just self learn
your way into data science to have some
understanding of what you're doing I
don't know from the other side like some
people will say hey you gotta do your
traditional statistics courses yeah so
because maybe that's the only way we're
force you to understand all these issues
that could come up okay so he's saying
that yeah he's saying the dangers of
teaching yourself everything is that you
might know you might not know what type
of things to be aware of or what type of
things an expert that's teaching a
course would inform you of right so even
though it's self learning a lot of the
guides will cover some of that stuff's a
lot of the books that you'll use to
learn or the courses you'll learn online
will cover that you can take especially
in the foundational courses if you feel
like you need a class you can go to a
community college and take a statistics
course if you don't feel comfortable
with the ones online though a lot of
courses online now really cover end to
end they have an entire curriculum that
they would teach in the college course
so it's kind of a balance you know if
you don't want to pay for a degree you
can probably find some open version of
actual course from a university but the
other thing is about what I mentioned
about getting feedback and finding
people in the industry that know what
they're talking about so when you post
information online you can ask you can
say to somebody you know am I thinking
about this right alright I got this
weird result what is it that I'm
so you can definitely dive in deeper in
some areas and ask people that would be
teaching those courses so like I
personally I did a master's degree long
after my bachelor's degree in systems
engineering which has some overlap with
data science but had been a long time
since I did a lot of that math I was
struggling with it but also I'm really
glad that I took a machine learning
course that focused on the math behind
the machine learning and it was really
hard for me but that really gave me a
footing that I probably wouldn't have
sought out myself with with self
learning so that's an area where you
know if I were just going straight from
being a sequel data analyst and database
designer which was my background trying
to become a data scientist I might seek
out a professional course in machine
learning
but that same information was also in
the textbook that we were using in the
course well and that depends on the job
I got a job as a data scientist and did
not have to do anything from the
elements of statistical learning book if
they didn't give me a test like that so
it really depends and certain certain
jobs are going to expect a statistician
I interviewed for a job and that would I
told them ahead of time that was before
I was you know felt like I was fully at
the point where I can dive in and
actually even when I got the job that I
got I didn't feel like I was fully ready
but I was ready enough for that specific
job which was kind of a data analyst
slash data scientist so I could kind of
grow into the data science role so if
you're not fully comfortable that area
you know don't apply for a job where
they're going to give you a statistics
test to get the job but yes you do need
a foundation and there are resources
more strict than we there's like more
hurdles for you including having the
actual official degree well and that
that may become true with more
universities having a data science
degree however I've found at least in
the early years of University suddenly
jumping into data science they're
rebranding another program so it might
be like a statistics program and they
bring in a computer science professor
and say we know of a data science
program but yes I mean you're right
there there are some things that you
really need the technical foundation and
it's worth taking a course if you feel
like that's a big gap for you but you
don't have to take a whole degree
program to do that yeah yes so there's
resources at the end of the presentation
but I'm not going to run through all
them here I'll share the slide
presentation so look for my slides you
can go to becoming a data scientist calm
it's not up there yet but I'll share the
slides there and a blog post and I have
a lot of lists but they're not even
linked to anything so that way you'll
have the links and you want to go look
everything up all right well I think I
wrap up here if anyone has more
questions you can come see me afterwards
thank you